hi dr. Peterson over the last couple
weeks and further back you talk a lot
about consciousness and the importance
of it I was hoping to get your opinion
on an issue consciousness that has often
seen Christianity among other groups and
politics kind of clashed so I'm hoping
to get your views on the consciousness
or lack thereof of a human fetus and how
that impact your views abortion whatever
they are and any like thank you thank
you okay so the first question is do I
have an answer for that that's a good
enough answer to actually reveal I know
I don't but I can flail about a little
bit around it abortion is clearly wrong
I don't think anybody debates that you
wouldn't recommend that someone that you
love have one
okay now having clarified that that mere
statement doesn't eliminate the
complexity of the situation the first
question is is should everything long be
illegal that's a tough question
everything that's wrong isn't illegal
then there's the additional complication
of the difference let's say in gravity
regarding the problem in relationship to
men and women and we don't know how to
deal with that having said that I would
say that it's actually the wrong
question there's a something Leonard
Cohen said once he said that in a
massacre there's no decent place to
stand and what he meant by that was
sometimes you're where there is no good
decision left no matter what you do it's
wrong so then the question is how did
you get there
well let's say you're in a position
where you are inclined to seek an
abortion the question is how did you get
there now we have a lot to straighten
out about sexual relationships between
men and women in the modern world
they're bent and warped and demented out
of shape one of the things I see with
young people for example is that they
will engage in sexual acts with one
another that they would not talk about
with one another
I mean couples will do that for that
matter like married couples will do that
but they're married that's that's a
different story it seems to me that if
you are willing to engage in a sexual
act with someone with whom you would not
discuss that act you probably put the
cart before the horse so the discussion
regarding the legality of abortion is
nested inside a larger discussion about
the morality of abortion and that's
disconnected inside a larger discussion
about the proper place of sexuality and
human behavior and to me that's the
level at which the problem needs to be
addressed now I don't have the answer to
that you know because the old answer was
get married that was a good answer and
it's an answer that people should still
listen to but we'll put that aside
momentarily I had a client at one point
who was I don't know she was probably
I'm not I'm going to disguise her in a
variety of different ways she was 27
2008 should come from a relatively
conservative background quite a timid
fearful person and also not very well
not sophisticated in relationship to
relationships and she'd never had sex
well there's a bunch of things she'd
never done well the answer from me to
her wasn't continued to be timid about
everything because that wasn't working
out for her she needed to go have some
adventures now sexual adventures like
other adventures are dangerous and so
you have to be very careful when you
encourage people to go out and have
adventures but
but but too much timidity and caution
also constitutes a pathway to perdition
let's say you can't just say to people
in the modern world well you know sex
till you're married unless you're going
to get married when you're very young
and perhaps you should I don't know
about that but I don't think that we're
mature enough as a culture to have a
serious discussion about sexual
propriety especially in the aftermath of
the birth control pill and we seriously
need to do that and we have it and so I
think the eternal debate about abortion
horrible as it is is a it's the surface
manifestation of a much deeper problem
now I talked a little bit today about
the utility of marriage like the
spiritual utility of marriage and that's
something that I think we're so
immaturely cynical as a culture like we
don't we're not wise enough to look at
an institution like marriage and to
really think about what it means and
what it signifies it signifies a place
that people could tie the ropes of their
lives together so that they're stronger
it signifies a place where people can
tell the truth to one another it
signifies a place where sexuality can
properly be integrated into life that's
no easy that's no easy task it's a place
where children at least in principle can
be put first and foremost as they should
be once they exist and so there's a much
broader discussion that has to happen I
think before any concentration on the
legality of abortion is liable to get
anywhere at all that's what it looks
like to me so that's the best I can do
with that question
you